So we were very high above them this moment.
We were maybe 2000 meter above the summit and then maybe 5 or
600 meter above ground above the valley.
It was like moon. Just magic.
Damn, bro, you're giving me full load big time.
I want to be in front of us like South Africa is magic.
Pakistan is magic. Yeah, flying is magic.
Yeah, flying is. Always magic.
What is up everyone? Welcome back to your weekly dose
of awesomeness here at Para Lining Atlas Podcast.
I'm your host, Aninder Singh, and joining us today is a name
we all know very well from the hike and fly races.
And I'm talking about none other than the man himself, Damien
Lacaze. Damien, this is such a big
honour. Welcome to the show.
Thank you. Thank you very much, Damien.
I want to start with a little bit of your history because you
come from a sports background which was not para lining.
And you were fairly active even before you got in the sport.
So how did the art of flight come into your life?
I come from mountain ring. My father was a mountain guide.
So I started quite early to to climb and to go in mountains.
And I discovered our lighting quite late at 22 with, yeah,
with mountain friends for joking.
We just made a cruise to to say, well, we are bored to to walk
down from the mountain. We we would like to try to fly
down. And I felt in love immediately
of this sport. It was amazing.
I immediately above a wing on eBay. eBay.
Yeah, on eBay. That's a long time ago.
And and yeah, after I tried to learn alone.
But yeah, like every young pilot, I made some mistake and I
made some yeah fear, but no accident.
And after I began to learn more classically with a school and
the one year later I made my first, not big, but big for me,
ecstasy flights. And after two years, I started
to enter in in the in the school to became an instructor and I
discover a competition in this because of that, because I
needed to make competitions to enter in this formation.
For me, it was a like AI don't know if the name is correct in
English, but revelation really big.
Yeah, I liked it a lot immediately.
Yeah, I didn't know I I had this kind of competition spirit, but
I enjoy it race in Barrack Landing since the first time
because it worked of course. And that's my first competition
experience. For maybe two or three years I
continued to mix mountain rain climbing and paragliding and it
was difficult to manage all these activities plus my job of
course. And after some years, I decided
to slow down mountain, to focus, to fly more and, and I thought,
OK, if I want to come back in mountain later, I can of course.
But for now, I want to learn how to fly far and to fly fast and
and that's my main hobby now I'm focused on that.
You're going to call this a hobby when you get on the podium
of exalts. Yeah, but no, I'm talking about
yeah, maybe 10 years ago. I was not thinking about Exalt
yet. I actually wanted to ask you
that because mountaineering itself is quite challenging.
You get to scale 4005 thousand meter peaks in Alps I believe.
No in Alps, yeah, maximum it's 4800, but yeah, I I went in
Pakistan as well to more to fly than to climb, but we climb 5
thousand 5500 peaks yeah, but yeah, it's challenging is all
those skills, but it's I think it's helped me a lot to progress
quickly in paragliding. Just not the skills, but my
mind. Because when you are, I don't
know, I don't the more than English.
But you are OK with a mountain ambiance or a mountain feeling
which is sometimes scary or dangerous.
Your mind is already OK with that.
It's quite the same in paragliding.
If you fly mountains, sometimes you have to manage some risks.
Some storms, some winds come from you.
You cannot understand all the factorial you have during a
flight and sometimes you have to accept it can be dangerous or
afraid and if your mental said stop because you are not used to
support that you can be traumatized or afraid and stop
to fly then fortunately my mind was stronger.
I'm sometimes I'm afraid, sometimes I'm asking, OK, there
now is too much or too dangerous, but when it's
finished for my mind it's OK, it's finished now I'm focused on
the next goal. I can analyse what's happened
and do not the same mistake further.
But I, yeah, my mind is strong for that.
I can not forget, but I can let this fear out and go on.
I think the cross training is the right word.
When you train for one sport, it helps you in multiple sports
that the mountaineering experience helped you in
parallelizing. Yeah, on the mind aspect, I'm
sure, yeah. When you began the sport like 22
is fairly a young age, maybe not for Frenchies because you guys
started teenagers, but a lot of other people get later.
Did you had any long term goals or like the vision?
Because eventually reaching Exiles and getting on the podium
and being a part of the whole tribe is quite special.
What was your vision like when you Yeah, you will be
disappointed. I was starting to fight like a
hobby no more at the beginning, and for the two first years was
hobby no more. But I was enjoying a lot.
But I had no goal at all, neither competition and for me
itself was, yeah, inaccessible. I'm not this kind of guy who is
able to fix big goals and to work on it to reach them.
For me, I have a big lack of self-confidence.
If I see a nice goal for me, I start to think it's not
possible. It's too difficult when I start
to fly. I didn't watch the races yet,
but I was watching the cross country races, I was watching
the good French team like Jean, Marcaron, Julian, the old guys
now but and I was thinking there are machines I never I will able
to fly with them, they are too strong.
And two or three years later I was in French team, but it was
impossible to fix that goal because for my mind it's not
accessible. I'm working step by step at a
certain moment to see, oh, maybe I have the skills to do that.
I don't know how to explain that, but man, it's only patient
and yeah, how will fly and skills developed.
Yeah, I'm not working on that goal because for me it's not
possible. After some years I discovered
some skills and I think, OK, now maybe I can think to that.
And that was the same for when I heard about this race for the
first time. I was thinking, what the hell is
this race? It's crazy.
It's too difficult. The men are.
It's like, for me, it was impossible to run 160K in a row.
The first time I heard about, I was thinking that it's
impossible for maybe two or three years.
I was watching this race like a crazy thing, impossible for
classic humans and and I started to think about compete one day,
maybe after after supporting Benoit in 2017 and I apply in
19. I was not selected and they took
me in 21. But yeah, it took me lots of
time to accept in my mind, maybe I have the skills to try to do
that. How many hours were you when you
got selected for ex Alps? Like how many hour pilot were
you when I was selected for the first time?
I usually I fly around 200 to 250 hours by year, but before it
was a bit less. I don't know, maybe 1000, maybe
1200. I don't know really.
I don't count every years. I I I know approximately how
many hours I do each year, but I never to try to accumulate all
these. How?
Let's talk about your mindset a little bit because climbing is
challenging when you expose yourself to risk.
It needs a lot of preparation and a certain way of being at
peace with having some expectations but making them
sometimes or not making them sometimes.
Did you prepare the same way in parallel lighting or do you see
some changes from your mindset and climbing to parallel
lighting? Because a lot of people use
parallel lighters as safety descent tools, so a lot of
climbers are switching to paragliding.
So I'm just wondering what are the similarities here?
I think climbers and mountain Mountaineers when they started
paragliding, they're from a true paraglider point of view.
No Mountaineer guy are crazy because there are No Fear and
the guy who only fly with which who lives in a flat land with no
mountains cannot understand what's going on in the mind of a
strong Mountaineer or strong climber.
Because I used to manage some risk that I used to count on
their skills to be safe and that they are used to have a strong
mind to to stay focused in the. Sketchy, yeah.
Difficult situation. They are both solo sports.
Because at the end of the day, you're alone on the mountain
even if you have a teammate. And same in para lighting, even
if you're flying as a team, you are the one who has to fly the
glider, just like you are the one who has to climb the
mountain. So I think there are a lot of
similarities. You can be a very strong pilot,
why not a world champion? And you are not forced to have
this kind of mind because the competitions are not.
Yeah, it's on the safety places most of the time.
Most of the time. And that's not in High Mountain.
You didn't take any big risk for your life.
You can make some crazy thing in Himalaya with your rings and
didn't make any comps for me. Adventure flights and
competition are two different disciplines and you can do both
of them, of course. But you don't need to have a
strong mind and a strong balls for the Hood pilots.
That's yeah, that's. Two way of flying, two way of
life indeed. Let's talk about exalts.
From being not accepted to being accepted, to finally standing on
the podium. This is a gap of, I say six
years. What was your training like in
this six years and how did you evolve as a parallel pilot
during 2019 to 2023? Yeah, you will be disappointed
because I started with a really amateur approach.
I started I can fly in 2016, my first really first race, short
race. It was born to fly in in ANSI
with absolutely not no specific train and no train.
I just walked in the mountain to make some I can fly like usually
no more, never trained on the flat.
And one month before the race I thought, oh, maybe I can try
this race. It looks nice and it was still a
hobby in my mind. So I find a friend and we go to
race on this nice race, but with absolutely no training.
My first race I won it by chance because I made a good move on
the first day of flight and Kriegel was here, so I was quite
proud to beat him. But it was pure, pure lucky and
that on the day too, I just had need to run 30 KS to win and it
was over. And it made maybe one week to
recover because my legs were totally broken after 30 KS
because I was not trained, not fit at all.
After that I made another race the same in 2019, and it was
quite the same, No, with no train.
And I start to train for 20 ones for the Excel after my
selection. But before, yeah, I was quite
relaxed and I hadn't any goal, any performance goal in this
kind of race until 23, I think. Because in 21, when I come,
yeah, when I applied, it was for the adventure, sporting
adventure and human adventure. This race made me dream for
years. It was a victory just to be on
the start line. I just wanted to smile, take all
the good vibes on the road and enjoy this amazing race.
But ranking was not a goal at all on the first years and after
I when I decided to come back in 23, yeah, I take the thing more
seriously and I start to train regularly to work on my mental
side. I was lucky as well because all
what all the thing I wanted to improve compared to 21 was walk
at World and I did almost no mistakes.
I was a bit lucky at the end as well and yeah, it was almost a
perfect race. Wow.
That's such a nice thing. To hear yeah.
And that's why it made me more than one year to decide to come
back in 25 because after this yeah, kind of experience
finishing second on the on this race, it wasn't a goal.
It wasn't even a dream. It was too big for me and and I
thought why I want I would like to come back.
I will disappointed for sure. The ranking can be a motivation
because I was 80 percent, 90% sure I will not do better.
I find motivation to come back because thanks to my mental
coach, you maybe you have you will have some difficulty to
understand that. But in my mind it was impossible
for me to win because I have the I had the sensation.
I was my my skills, my level in flight in the ground was way
below than the others. And in French we said the
complex of the imposter means I I have the sensation to not be
in my world because the other are stronger than me much.
And that's a big problem for me since I'm a child, I always,
yeah, I'm quite shy, shy and with lack of self-confidence.
And I always thinking that's not for me because it's too
difficult. For me.
Winning the Isabel was not possible at all.
And I cannot even imagine that. So after my podium was
unexpected, my mental coach said me, maybe you can find
motivation if you try to stop, to forbid, to forbid to win, not
to go to win, but just allowed you to, if all is perfect again,
maybe you are able to win. And that's a good way to work.
And yeah, we did that. We work a lot on my
self-confidence, my skills, on the yeah, I learned to accept.
I have some skills and some strength and some weakness and
and we work on that. And now I started to accept,
yes, I have some, yeah, some strengths and some part like my
mind and my, yeah, my I I know my mind is strong now.
And I also have some likeness, my physical part, yeah,
especially on the ground, on the flat.
But I know if I did well, I'm able to win if all is good.
And that's, yeah, for me, that's a really new things.
And I, yeah, I don't know if I like it, but I feel maybe a bit
less, less. How is the world's really weak?
No, weak. But you know the word in French.
We should. Have had a Google translator but
no, no worries, understand the context.
I started to feel like an athlete and not like an amateur,
but you take me a long way. And you're smashing podiums in
one of the world's toughest adventure, and you're out here
competing with the best of the best.
So I think you are definitely an athlete, don't be so hard, but
would you be comfortable talking a little bit about your mental
coach? How do you guys tackle a
challenge? Like when there's a challenge in
front of you that you have to overcome psychologically, what
is the mindset or what is the road map that you and your
mental coach? So you guys train mentally
basically? Mainly it's open discussion with
her, because now she's a really good friend.
We started every mental coach with some tips, some tools to
fix your mind that keep concentrated, manage mistakes,
how to react after a mistake, how to stay calm with influence.
We said coherence cardiac to listen you hurt you hurt and try
to calm it. Respiration, no breathing.
Yeah breathing exercises and quickly we didn't stopped, but
we talked a lot. We yeah we started to talk a lot
with no plane just talking about what scared me, what's worrying
me and what's in what kind of way I feel strong or weak and
and we different we she made an Excel tableau.
I don't know Excel Excel cheat. Cheat.
Yeah, sorry with my fear, for example, my main fear or my main
NK2 to worry Yeah and and she give me some homework to Yeah,
why to fear what you worries, what you don't want to see or to
leave during a race. And after we will try to find
some way to to overpass that it can be only a sentence, a word
to keep concentrated to not screaming when when you make a
mistake, for example, and to keep focus something stupid.
But I'm not able to say no to somebody because I'm too shy.
That was a fair for me in the team if they give me a way or a
route to follow. And if I'm not OK with that, I'm
not able to say no because, yeah, I know that are thinking
about for a long time and and I just fly.
So I cannot think about it. And so it's difficult for me to
say no. I don't want to do that because
I work for nothing. And yeah, she just tried to make
me understand they are making the race for me and that that's
not a problem. If I said no, we are working
together to find another way. It's quite simple.
But for me it's difficult. Yeah.
And we have lots of, lots of thing to to do to fix this kind
of mental since 21. I saw a huge difference in my
mind on the way how I accept the mistakes, how I accept, for
example, a penalty. And yeah, before I was so sad.
So it was so difficult. 2 days. And yeah, this year I took six
hour penalty and I just said, OK, now we will take this time
to rest and to make some massage.
And the my supporters was looking at me.
OK, no problem. But they told me that after but
they were impressed on my reaction because for them, I
they were sure I will explode on the scream.
And the no, I was tired. I was really exhausted.
So I think it helped me. I just take took this time to
rest and and. Try to not waste waste energy by
yes screaming. Things that have already
happened. Yeah.
And yeah, I think she Delfina, she's her name of mental coach.
Yeah, she did a great job in five years.
Amazing, and that's good to hear.
How does the physical side of things look for you when you
plan out an adventure? Is there a certain?
Where you train yourself or do you have specifics that you
train for? Yeah, since I start to take this
race more seriously, since 23, I took a trainer, a coach.
The first one was Laurie Genovese.
Do you know her? Yeah, of course.
She. Was in the race as.
Well, yeah, it's a good friend and she's a physiotherapist and
she's coach and a very good pilot.
She knows quite well. We made one year together in 23
and this year I changed for a French guy from my valley, but
very famous called from the in the training meal.
And he's the coach from the French team of scheme of ski
mountaineering and as well as some athletes like, I don't know
if you know him, Benjamin Medellin, really famous
alchemist. And he didn't know I can fly
races at all because he, no, he's not flying, but the
projects interest him a lot. And and he has a different
approach of the training than Lori.
And I like it it at all. And moreover, the relation where
was different because Lori was a friend and she, she helped me
just for fun and because she liked me.
And with Leo it was like professional, I was paying him.
So it the relation were different.
And I think it was better because I was forced to respect
more his exercise. And he, yeah, like a contract,
he called me every two days or three days and asked me how is
it? And I yeah, it was more
professional and I think it was better for me.
I needed that. And I also tried to increase my
volume of training around 20%. My main problem is to is the
time because I have a wife, two daughters, a job and and I have
to fly and to train. So it's for me, it's a challenge
to find mores on 10 or 12 hours each week to train and it's
almost nothing. Sorry, that's quite hard with.
10 if you compare with Fellow or Maxim, they did the double, they
did 20, maybe 25. For me it's not possible because
I'm not enough time. And for my mind it was difficult
too, because that's another point on mental coaching.
But sometimes when I discuss that with Delphine, I said I'm
less maritime. I don't know that.
I I told her it's normal if I don't win or I don't perform
because I train half than them. And she answered, are you really
thinking you, you are less, you deserve less than the other
because you train less. And she told me, look at the
others, this is their job. They train and that's all.
Figure out how the family. But his main job is to train,
nothing else. You are indeed.
Look at you, you have a job, you have tutors and you train more.
So do you really think you deserve less than the other?
You are making such an effort to be there and to train and you
deserve for sure. And for me it was the opposite
because I cannot train much. I was lower so always the same
thing and I always seeing the bad things.
Can you talk a little bit about the training program that your
trainers decide for you? What did that look like?
It was moving every month, some strange exercises, some interval
of course and the volume a maximum of volume with my three
times and the try to mix activities to not get injured.
Some bikes in winter, some ski mountain ring, some climbing as
well. And after maybe March we stopped
all the other activities and made all the training by foot to
adapt my body to the running side and try to not go in
different directions. But the main goal my body is
quite complicated to train because I got some small
injuries and pain quickly if I push too much.
That's not my main, my, yeah, my strength, like Maxim can push
harder every weeks and then never get injured.
And I'm not like that. I'm not fast.
If I try to push too much, I have some pain coming in the
knees, in the hip, in the muscles.
So my main challenge, and the first thing I said to Leo, was
I'm really fragile and I don't want to get injured.
We tried to take care of my body all the year and we manage a
knee pain during six months in the winter and the beginning of
spring, but at the end we managed to avoid it and and be
almost be prepared at the start. Did you have any specific
nutritional plans that you? Were working on no no, I didn't
find energy and time to think about that.
I'm eating quite healthy but I don't count how many calories I
eat this year. I tried to take care of what.
Quantity of yeah, carbonate of sugar I hate during efforts, but
the food was not yeah, was not controlled.
Damian, I was on your website and I saw that you're into
public speaking as well. You go out and do some seminars
with companies and one of those topics was risk management.
Is there a certain blueprint that you have devised on how to
manage risk when you're out there chasing adventures or any
challenge where there is an accepted risk that you go and
then there are some goals that you have to achieve.
So what is your strategy in managing the risk?
I'm not sure I have a real strategy, but of course you just
said it. I cannot do activities like
paragliding or mountain ring without risk acceptability.
Yeah, it's, yeah. The risk in paragliding if you
do a big mistake is to die. And it's the same in mountain.
And you have to accept the rules.
Of course. We always try to avoid that, to
learn some skills, to not be in danger and to keep a safe
margin. But this part of the game, if
you cannot accept that, you cannot really progress or push
on some limits. So I'm lucky about that because
I said that and when I'm when I'm in a tricky situation in
mountain or in flight, I have the capacity to focus on what I
need to do now. All the other bad things in my
head will stop or go away for this moment.
I'm able to not to think to my daughter's, to my house or to my
creditor. I don't know whatever at the
moment when it's tricky or risky or windy, I'm able to stay
focused on what I need to do now to exceed from this situation.
And and after there is. Yeah, maybe after there is some
place for fear or for, I don't know, for some debriefing and
say, OK, it was it was too much. I have to avoid this situation
for the next times. And and I don't like to to take
risk for nothing. But risk is part of my life as
well. I some people who never do that
or who are not mountainous are thinking the climbers or the
some paragliders. I crazy guys and and don't like
the life. And for me, you take risks
because you have the feeling your skills and your experience
are enough to keep you alive. And this feeling is really
amazing. Take this risk because you
really like the life. I feel really good when I have a
feeling I'm in safety because of my skills and my decisions.
Maybe in a dangerous area, dangerous mountain or flight and
the yeah, for me it's that's the definitions of in France, we
said volleyball, free flight. We have the capacity of making
good or bad decision and the and making yeah, dangerous thing or
not, or safe flight or tricky flight.
And that's in this kind of modern society, that's a luxury
to to be able to put yourself in a situation where you are
responsible of your safety. And that it's yeah, it's
difficult in this society to accept that because now the risk
taking risk is almost forbidden. And the Latin mountain, you do
what you want and you are responsible, responsible of you,
of your life and your safety. And I like this feeling.
Taking irrational risk happens sometimes and we are not
prepared for that risk, but it surprises us.
How do you debrief after that? What is your way to get back
your confidence and make sure you don't repeat it?
Irrational risk can happen. The worst for that is race is
because because you saw you see the although I like flying for
example and and you don't want to lose the 1st and you are
thinking oh they are flying so I can do it.
And you can forgot you your skills and your limit and and
did and make some stupid things because you have not a skills or
experience to manage this risk. It can be windows, storm or I
don't know. And but in other way, each time
I push further my limit of what I was thinking, what is possible
to do in paragliding? Each time I I discover OK, this
wind is possible. It's possible to fly with this
kind of wind. It was in competition because
it's impossible to train at home or with no goal in windy
conditions because it's really afraid and we if we are no no
goal or no motivation, you a normal human said to himself,
it's stupid that I go landing Even Kregel said it's not
possible to train to that condition if you are not in
competition because of the mindset stop very quickly.
So you need this challenge You need this yeah, this motivation
to to learn. But in other and it's dangerous
because you don't know where is the limit at the beginning when
you discover that and the limit is sometimes.
And that's the main problem of the icon flight comes because of
course on a small race of two days, for example, the
organization can manage the weather and go where the wind is
not strong or fix some limits. But in a race like it's not
possible and the limit is fixed by the hot plates and all the
Atlas has not the same limits and the same skills.
I never thought I was over over past my safety margin.
I lots of time I discover I it was possible to fly in wind
quite strong and two days before I was thinking it was not.
So I discovered new way of flying thanks to Krieger, thanks
to other pilots who show me it's it was possible.
And and I in in my head I was yeah, I made some debrief.
OK, we have to phone is ugly, but it's flyable sometimes.
But it's hard to fix a limit. It's not mathematics.
It's always different and it's only feelings that's the problem
because you have to try and to say, OK, it's manageable or not.
And in most of the case, when you are in flight and it's too
strong, you can still manage to land quite safely before it's
too late. But it's just experience and
feeling and it's complicated to to explain and and I don't
advise to to anything to, to test that without many
experiences and knowing what they want to do.
The real risk in paralleling is to die.
Really. We have always thinking that do
that all the time and try to keep some.
Good margin indeed. I think I was speaking with your
coach Julian, and he said that only get into the sport if
you're willing to, yeah, die for it, to put it simply, because
it's quite unforgiving. We all have to choose our
decisions carefully. When it comes to choosing
decisions, team is critical. Even though it's a solo sport,
you had to pick a team in exhalps and right now in this
World Cup, you guys are here with the French team.
So how do team dynamics influence your flying style and
what is the way to find your tribe or your team?
How do you find people that are trustworthy?
It's always difficult because you need lots of skill,
different skill, really different, and it's impossible
to find all the skill in one person.
The teams are growing and growing each years now.
This year we were seven. We were 567 no more.
We are 9/6 in the van, three and three in each van plus me and
Julian was the coach, was with me at home with the radio and
the life tracking for the coaching and the strategy and
Delphine, my mental coach was here by phone each time I
needed. So it was quite big team and the
first time we were only three. It's growing a lot, but it's
quite a challenge to find the right person because you have to
find the right skills with this big team.
It's a human experience as well. And you have, yeah, you have to
manage this potentially human problems and all the persons
have to to take care of each other and to make a good
emission. And it 11 bad person, one bad
people is enough to fuck all the team.
It's because with the days quite exhausting, the lack of sleep
and it became quite tricky. And yeah, it's a challenge.
And until for me, until May, I was not sure to find the right
person one was missing. And the most important for me is
called the Sherpa, the man who is working with me in mountains,
taking my non mandatory stuff and flying down after.
It's really hard to find this guy to be very fit, to fly quite
well because I don't want to think about him behind me, to
think about his safety. So I have to be sure he's a good
pilot to take the right decision and to land safely because some
flights are quite tricky even for him.
And in general this kind of guys are on the starting line.
Fortunately in France we have lots of young pilots dreaming
for exiles and and who wants to make a first experience and to
discover this race from inside after bomb to fly on the finish
line. The third guy was a young French
guy, 4024 years old. And I just asked him to come
like random, random discussion and he was so exciting about
that. And it's happened like that true
revelation because he was so nice, so strong and so good
person. So it was the perfect guy to to
complete the team at the last moment.
They all helped me a lot to take decision as well to to make some
plan, some strategy. And after I was able to decide
which one suit the most for. Me I'm curious how did Julian
assist you on the phone because he is usually known to take care
of cross country comps like racing apparently World Cups and
stuff like that. But I can fly is also how does
Julian if you're not letting out any secrets.
His first war was the strategy in flight, not by foot.
Making flight plans. What?
Sorry, watching the life tracking and give me some advice
and some information about what what are doing the others and
and then finally he made much more than that because he's AI.
Don't know if you saw him here, but he's a really coach, not a
mental coach, but he manage mental athlete and he knows
what's in how head during flights and during his out.
It was amazing. It was like he's in my head.
He was help me to calm down, help me to keep pushing, help me
to stay calm, especially on the end of the flight to Yeah, to
turn in small thermals to finish well, each days until the really
end of thermals. And it was really a full to have
somebody 18 hours by the behind his screen with the life
trucking. And they said me, OK, you can
maybe you can go a bit on the right because the author took
the thermal here. OK, you have time.
Don't worry. It's 8:30.
You have time to to cross this path.
And all the time it was like that.
And it it was really helpful. Yeah.
He's a really good guy. Did you speak in the air as
well? Like basically.
Yeah. And direct directly with a
special application on the phone called Zillow.
OK. And it's like radio, but with
the phone you have to tap and press Zillow, right?
SLEELO, I've heard about that. Damien, what is the best part
about Excel and what is the worst part about this year?
I'm just talking about the lifestyle.
Hike and fly is a very exciting lifestyle for a lot of people
and just with any risk versus reward, it has it's own ups and
downs. From your perspective, who has
seen the climbing only side of the sport plus the flying side
of the sport? What is the best and what is the
worst that you look in high can fly races?
I think the best for me the it's the feeling you you have when
you finished day perfectly. When you don't waste any
terminals and you land just before the deadline, you are
satisfied about your day. You are looking back what you
did on this day and each morning when you start you, it's
impossible to know where you finished the day.
But if you start to think about what's going on, it's almost
impossible because you start to think, OK, I have 200 meters
appeal to walk, then maybe 150 KS flight.
Then I have to sign a panel, then maybe walk 200 meters more.
And the days are really huge with no hands.
It's crazy, unfinished days. And when you are on the yeah, at
the end of the day, you are thinking about that and you're
just thinking, OK, I made all these things.
It's it's crazy. It's unbelievable.
It was not possible to think about all these challenge on the
morning. And I like this meaning you to
take the piece one piece after one and just think about the
first piece and after the second, the height, then the
flight and then maybe a tricky flight and after maybe a long
run on the road. But just thinking about the
first one and not the whole cake because it's too big to digest
in one time. And I like this feeling.
And the worst, of course, that's the tricky days.
Storm wind on the course race, quite long race.
You are sure statistically will happen maybe only one day, but
it's enough to feel fear or be in danger.
That's the worst part of this game that you have to to think
about and you have to be prepared.
So you you have to know your limits.
You have to know what you can do, what you don't want to do
and, and stay. Yeah, quite rigid with that.
Try to not be influenced by by the others.
And yeah, we saw some footage from Exalts in Milano in the
film, some crazy take off. When we took off from this
place, it was maybe one or two hours earlier.
It was much less strong. But the take off I saw, I don't
know, remember who is it, maybe a Spanish or Italian guy.
It was hell and I don't want to leave that anymore neither.
So for me that's the limit do. Thoughts like quitting come to
your mind when things get challenging and races like this
that this is not worth it. Maybe I should just give it up.
Clear. Yeah, yeah, don't on this ways,
I don't remember I said no or stop one times.
We took some difficult choices, but it was more to avoid this
kind of situation. For example, on the way back to
Locarno from France, we decided to cross the main Ridge to pass
in the valley in Switzerland because it was focused on big
storms in our stand in the Italian side.
So we managed to cross and finish in Locarno on the night
we decided to not go on the storm.
So it was a difficult option because it if it's not working,
I landed in suites and it was not, it was quite longer and
really hard to exceed by foot. But yeah, I'm quite happy about
this choice and the strategy because I was safe and I'm not
in a tricky situation like Tim, for example.
Tim was in the storms and he was, yeah.
I think he now he's traumatized because he was climbing in like
hail with yeah, with no snow, but I don't know the name.
English Hail. Yeah.
And he may maybe 1000 of stalls to go down.
And after he was crying and his race was finished, he stopped.
Yeah. And yeah, yeah, yeah.
And that's why we choose to avoid that and to pass on the
north of Massif, so. He's a pretty good acro pilot.
Yeah, pretty good pilot. Like he knows how to handle his
glider and if he can get scared. Yeah, because you can be the
best pirate of the world. Storm is a storm, and it's more
powerful than you. Much more.
Are you comfortable talking about it?
What happened? Basically, he just got sucked up
and then he had to stall his way out.
Not really, because I don't know all the story.
I I didn't talk with him. The.
Reason I'm asking is because the moment cloud suck happens,
stalls are not really helpful. Nothing really helps in cloud
suck. What is the way to get?
Out of a cloud? Maybe it's to fly straight on
the on the yeah, on the good way and but I don't know what's
happened exactly. Yeah and I know he was on the
South side of Monjos called the on the big massive more than
4000 meters. Maybe there is mountains
everywhere on and he was afraid to hurt the ground and the dog.
I don't know what's happened exactly so I can talk, but I
know he has the best feeling in the pilot is incredible in the
air. If he's afraid like that, maybe
it was not very comfortable to fly.
What makes? People like him who are
experienced enough to do that kind of stupidity, Is it just
like competition because you want to be better than the
other? Like you're willing to put your
life. Yeah, it's the that's why I try
to explain it. Sometimes it's try.
It's hard to say stop when we are flying.
It's you are thinking, OK, it's still OK, I can cross this Ridge
and we'll see behind. And you cross the Ridge and
behind it suddenly all dark or sucking and climbing everywhere
and it's too late. And when we saw you, you see
there are also pilots cross this area 30 minutes earlier.
Maybe you can think, OK, it's still good, but storm grow up
quite early and at a certain moment it's not good anymore.
But yeah, there's a limit. It's really hard to find and
it's harder, especially when we are on the ground, it's easier
to say, OK, no, it's not good. I work.
But when we are in flight, it's much more difficult to say, OK,
now it's too much. I go to land, especially if the
other already passed it. Yeah.
And sometimes when we think, OK, now I want to land, it's too
late. In the wind, it can be OK, but
in the storms when you want to land, it's already too late,
because when you want too late, that's means it's climbing
everywhere. And the two liners, the only
descent technique is to pull the G shoot and go spiral, right?
Yeah, I think team is really strong for that and the
installer can fall really quickly.
But do you carry AG shoot? Because I don't see anybody
using AG shoot too much weight. Damn, how did I forget that?
What is the descent technique for A2 liner then?
The simplest descent technique for A2 liner that I know is
spiraling, but stalls don't work that.
Well, if you manage to keep the backwind with really big errors,
you can fall at 8 meters by second and without any
centrifuge frost. OK, so just like backfly.
Yeah, backfly with big. Yeah, really huge Yeah, huge
backfly. So just do some SIVS before you
get into that. All right, interesting.
Any, I know we are running to the end of the time right now,
but is there any flight that was a learning experience for you
that was like, all right, this flight is something that I would
like to repeat or I would not like to repeat.
How have you experienced that over the period of competing in
Excels and I think? The not the last one, but the
last day and the day where the first arrived I was 40 days
behind because of my penalty and they flew to the last 10 Port
Lemos and I start to fly maybe one hour behind them because of
the penalties. Took off at 11 and I was
thinking to myself, OK, if I have a chance to catch them, I
need to fly fast, I need to be efficient.
And the day was perfect. It was a really nice cross
Country Day with high cloud bases and and I was really happy
about this flight because it was really nice.
I was quite good in my decision and speed and I managed to not
to catch them because there are too much in front.
But I was alone and I was flying faster than them and there there
were four. So I was, yeah, this feeling was
good. It's it was like if I was
nothing to lose because yeah, it's now or never do or die
after 998 days of race. It was like a race in the race.
And I liked to to play to that. I, I was not able to catch them,
but it was really nice. At the end when I arrived at the
at Lermos, I I had maybe one hour and one hour and 30 minutes
behind. So maybe 20 KS or 25 KS and
after it was over because I made another mistake and I bump out.
But this flight light was a really good memories and I would
would love to fly in that spirit during the race because it's
tricky to take this kind of sporting risk, not for my body,
but because when we fly with the group in competition, you don't
want to be isolated in front and low and and see the other fly
over you. And so you stay high, don't take
too much risk and fly most of the time quite slow.
And what I would like to do for the next not every time, but
yeah, to be able to feel this good vibes and to take some
sporting risk to to fly fast. It's yeah, it's like in cross
country. But in cross country if you bump
out, you lose a day. And that's doesn't matter in
such a race. If you bump out, you lose maybe
half a day. And it's hard to accept, but if
you can avoid this part and make confidence in your skills and be
sure it will be OK because you are a good pilot, you know how
to fly fast and you know the risk really is still acceptable.
You can. Yeah, you can maybe make the
difference. Indeed.
One thing that I've been very. Curious is be it exiles or be it
adventures. Triple C gliders are not being
used by a lot of people like most pilots prefer 2 liner DS.
Do you have any idea why triple CS are not being Yeah first
except the weight part because weight maybe can be made.
What is weight? Sorry the weight the heavy.
OK, so if we take away the weight like why don't people use
first? Because it's forbidden, the
limit for itself is ENDCR not allowed.
If it was allowed, the main difference between the swings
are the accessibility in the comfort and the take off and
landing on the CCC. You cannot really slow down the
ring before the store. This light wing accept to fly
quite slow and still fly and and it's really appreciate for top
landings or and more for the take offs with zeolite, for
example, you you can you can take off with backwind.
It's inflating really easy and that's the limit of CCC and the
big aspect ratio. Sorry, it's yeah, more of the
aspect ratio is big more it's difficult to inflate backwind
and yeah backwind and with by running and it's much more
demanding in tricky situation for top lands and and for yes
even for wind and for descending as well.
Funny how Daphne, a French pilot, could D wing and still
made it count in this World Cup. You know that she shows that the
difference between AD and a triple C is very negligible.
Yeah, but the Xeno 2 fly like CCCC almost it's a high, very
high D is it? Yeah, it's AD wing, but at the
beginning of the Xeno 2 honouring bring it and one
overcome with it. Oh really?
Yeah, Yeah, it's it fly really well, OK.
So that's interesting because to me D and triple CS were
classified. But zeolite, it's a true D but
Zeno 2 is much. If you race with zeolite and
Zeno is any day winning. Xeno is much more performance on
the zeolite, much more fast as well.
So when you go out on adventures 5006 thousand meters, would you
prefer having Xeno if the weight was not a problem, Yeah.
Last year in 24 we went to Pakistan with my friend Fabi to
climb and to fly. And we bring the two wings, the
zeolite for the combos and the Zeno 2 just for the trip.
For the big flights, they because I was afraid to take the
Enzo and the and the Zeno. Why for me was the perfect wing
for that. We made a 300 escape with Desino
and it's a safe wing, but still very performance.
So yeah, it was perfect. That's nice because I always
wonder that every 8000 meters summit or anybody who's trying
to reach from launch from there is always using.
For this kind of I prefer my zeolite of.
Course no, it has to be easier to launch for that.
But have you? Have you?
What is the highest you've launched from?
Launch, I think it's 600 and 506. 1000 thousand, yeah, OK.
6500 How's the launch conditions though over there?
Because the air is thin. Yeah, there is thin, but we had
a something like 15 or no. I did 2, two launch from this
altitude. The first was no wind on the
morning, but with perfect snow, hard snow.
So it was easy to run and the perfect slope as well.
It was difficult to run and we had to run quite fast, but with
the slope it was helping. The second one was on the
plateau, very flat and we were in the storm for three days with
Antoine, it was in 2018. It was completely impossible to
take off. We were waiting for a good
window with face win and we took this window 10 to 15 KS of
Goodwin to take off. Without doubt, it wasn't
possible to take off. Do you have any more exciting
adventures coming up? Maybe next winter we plan to
come back to South Africa to try to make big cross country free
distances with my friend and maybe one of those friends which
sell them. Three friends not.
It's not booked yet but it's a plan and maybe Pakistan next
June. Damn man sounds exciting.
You must be carrying oxygen. On all of these.
It's complicated to bring a bottle in the air and after one
week of accumulation we feel good at six or 700 meter in
flight. Of course know if we need to
walk, but flying at 6.5 it's OK after one week if you already
slept asleep at 4000 and then walk a bit higher during the
day. After one week you can fly at
6000 metre with no. Problems.
But South Africa, that's quite high.
That's like above ground level is like 4000 or more.
Yeah, the flat, it's a desert big plateau at one between 1 and
1.2000 metre. And sometimes the plan by cloud
bases can reach 6000 metres. It's crazy.
You are at the cloud base, you are at 5000 metres above
granite. It's amazing.
Do you see the ground? Yeah, you see the ground.
But yeah, it's right. The view, it's unbelievable.
And that's a decent kind of attitude.
You can have really strong wind and on the ground it's still
manageable. So that's why we we go there,
because you can expect some average flight really fast,
something like more than 50 or 60K per hour sometime that's
6000. You can fly with 60 KPH of wind,
Yeah. And yeah, you can.
For example the last light, if you manage to fight perfectly,
you can leave the clockwise at 6000 and die for 100 KS until
the ground. Because yeah, because you have
to 5000 meters to fly pushing by 50 or 60 kpa of wind and your
glade ratio is. Something like 1 is 200. 25 or
30? Yeah, it's crazy.
Man, that sounds exciting. Yeah, yeah, it's crazy.
But the really the perfect days, we didn't meet the perfect days
yet. The Clement did 550 KS two years
ago. But maybe the local pilot said
there is a potential for 700, I'm not sure, but 600 for sure.
Will it make sense to take a triple C at that location?
Yeah, of course we we fly with the Enzo.
That's what I was wondering. That's the first year you went
there. We bring Xeno 2 because we
didn't know the area, the thermal, the conditions and it's
really strong and the now we thought we are taking it's
possible with Enzo. But yeah, we have to keep in
mind it's, it's forbidden to, to land between 1:00 to 4:00
because it's it's hell on the ground with dust devil
everywhere with really strong thermal gusts.
The dust devil are crazy up to 2 or 300 metres above ground.
It's really huge with thermals up to 12 or 6 it sounds like.
A different planet you're talking.
About definitely not holidays, it's an an adventure.
But yeah, it's quite dangerous if you land on the middle of the
afternoon because, yeah, it's really strong, OK.
So there is no scope for low safe basically like you have to.
Maybe when he broke for the first time, the sense some
kilometers mark it was here and he made one or two low save with
almost 80 kilometers per hour of wind.
It was crazy. He he said if I didn't manage to
climb, I will die for sure. And when we your his track is
on, it's the second test if you are curious.
But it's crazy this day he took off at 11 and landed D46, I
think. So the flight was short and he
made 500 KS in with crazy average with old and bad wing.
Yeah, yeah, like it was AD wing but for almost 20 years ago.
What I'm wondering is. How do you make a loss about 80
kilometers an hour? What does a thermal look like at
that? I don't know how.
To visualize, how do you climb in such heavy wind I think.
This is different from there the terminal are drifting with the
wind and the climbing quite straight, but just drifting this
is not. Very slump, but it is just
moving. It's moving with the wind and
there is lots of triggers with some slopes with some bumps.
You can see the triggers because you can see the does the wheel.
Of course you can to go over them quite higher or over.
Of course there is a terminal above, but if you are low, yeah.
I never experienced to to zigzag between those devils.
Very low, but I don't want to try.
What is the thermal strength like?
Up to 10, maybe 12 metre by seconds sometimes on the good
days, yeah, it's strong, yeah. This is this how flying in Mars
would look like. Maybe in the next time we
wonder. We are tired of distance records
on Earth. We go to a different planet and
start chasing it. No, but Damien, I think we have
come to the end of the show with that.
And usually I ask my guests about a flight that has stuck
with them. But I think you already
mentioned that. Is there a flight that you can
always remember from your flight log so far that has emotionally
been that you would like to share?
I think one of my best flights was in Pakistan, my first
journey in Pakistan when we flew at almost 8000 meters close to
the China border with Antoine and we were in Voldi Rock with
total autonomy for 15 days and these days was amazing.
We hadn't any forecast weather and we took off this morning to
reach Carinabad because we plan to rest some days in this small
town. The day was amazing and in the
morning we reach more than 6000 meters and we float really,
really fast and the wind was quite strong, north wind and we
enter together in a thermal monster and after some yeah it
was 13 meters by second. I remember I had the GoPro and I
was watching the the value it was crazy 13 and when he stopped
how value shows 7700. So yeah, we left.
Why did you leave? Because we were close to cloud
base maybe 100 meters above, but it was dropping down and it was
the end that day. We landed at 6000 and to finish
our accumulation and then we just checked how GPS altitude
and both of you we flew at 7960 meters.
The barometers was wrong and the.
And how Ford GPS show the same altitude, if we have known that
before, we maybe we will turn, we have turned a bit to just to
reach 8000. But yeah, that was an amazing
experience. How does life feel when you're
so down high? Yeah, it was like on the moon
because of the summit was not very high, maybe 6000 or 6500.
So we were very high above them. It was not when Antoine broke
his multitude record on the Broad Peak, which is a 8000
summit. So it was just above the summit
in this. Yeah, this moment we were maybe
2000 meter above the summit and maybe 5 or 600 meters above
ground, above the valley. It was like moon, just magic.
Damn, bro, you're giving me full world big time.
What will be fun of this? Like South Africa is magic,
Pakistan is magic. Yeah, flying is magic.
Yeah, flying is. Always magic.
Even a soaring on the coast is magic.
Except for yesterday's task. Yeah, I know.
Yesterday's task, everybody was bumping out.
Oh, man. Do you mean, as I always say
when I hear experiences like this, that there's no one such
episode? We can do justice to your thing.
We'd love to call you back later when you have new stories and
new adventures. Thank you.
But now we have to run out of time.
And all I can say is, man, thank you so much.
It's been a real honour. And.
Thank you too to invite me. Yeah, keep rocking and we'll
stay tuned to your Instagram, YouTube, wherever you keep
posting, man. Thank you very much.
Hey everyone, for those of you who have listened this far, I
just wanted to drop in a note of thanks because you guys are the
ones who are actually making the difference.
It means the world to me whenever I see audience
retention rates remain high all the way to the end.
And I'd like to add on by saying that if you have liked the
content that you just consumed, do consider liking, subscribing
and dropping in a rating wherever possible.
Because that is one way we can let the algorithms of all of
these streaming platforms know that this episode is worthy of
being pushed out to more pilots in the community.
So collectively, you and I can make the sport a safer and a
more fun place to be. Well, on that note, thank you
once again for joining me today. And I'm really looking forward
to connecting with you in the next episode as well.
Until then, I'm going to say what I always say, and that is
stay tuned. Stay excited because this magic
is just getting started.